we all treat our money as our most
valuable asset but the thing that is
scarcest is our time what are some of
the things that you would do in an
organization outside of just the
structure of meetings that would
increase the productivity of the
organization you really have to just
rely on your people especially if you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're feeling
what is the biggest mistake you ever
made in business biggest mistake I ever
made in business was in 20 March of 2020
when I decided and announced to the
company right after the pandemic that I
would not lay anybody off
oh interesting you basically removed the
carrot and the stick it's a bad idea to
take the carrot and the stick away I
think what hurt me most was not that the
people who didn't perform well kept not
performing well it was the people that
all right guys bang bang I've got Howard
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start you've taken companies public
you've got a great business today uh
you've been highly successful as an
entrepreneur but you have a bunch of
productivity hacks which sound like
nonsense uh but you think differently
about how to be productive and then you
have these hacks that somebody can watch
this right now and immediately go
Implement in probably like two or three
extra productivity so the first one is
the idea of calendar zero what the hell
is calendar zero well you know
it's interesting because we all
treat our money as our most valuable
asset
but the thing that is scarceist is our
time yet we Dole out our time
every time we allow people to book
things up on our calendar and so think
of your calendar like it's your bank
account and it starts with
you know completely full when your
calendar is empty and every time someone
books a meeting you're they're
essentially taking a deposit out of your
bank account
and people's calendars get filled up and
clogged up and we uh we end up
with particularly in business with
people inviting us to all kinds of stuff
which frankly often is pointless
pointless meetings
so
there's a lot of folk there's a there's
a there's a focus around a thing called
inbox Euro which is how can I delete all
the emails in my inbox but what I've
always focused on is to try to get to
calendar zero now this is not an
absolute term there's still things that
are booked on my calendar for example
this session today or a thing that I
have to do at board meeting but I try to
really minimize what what ends up on my
calendar and when I look at my day the
less I have on my calendar I think the
better off it's going to be in fact the
wealthiest people I know tend to have
the least amount of stuff on their
calendars why is that that's like a
shocking thing to me and I've noticed
that as well the most successful people
have the least amount of things on their
calendar here's what successful people
have figured out number one you can
accomplish a lot in a very short amount
of time I want to tell you a story about
Teddy Roosevelt my favorite President
there's a lot of great books written
about him my favorite might be the bully
pulpit by Doris corns Goodwin uh so
Teddy Roosevelt used to hold five-minute
meetings
now I want you to think about a
five-minute meeting and when in business
you've ever scheduled a five-minute
meeting no one would ever do that there
would never be a five minute meeting on
your calendar but the president United
States used to put people in a line he'd
have them line up he'd have them come in
and there'd be a clock
and
when there's a five minute clock
counting down you'd be shocked
the forcing function of time
helps you accomplish so much people get
to the point right away decisions are
made you move on to the next thing and
so one day I was reading about TR doing
this and I was like well you know if the
POTUS can do this about
matters of extraordinary National
importance
I certainly in my company can
do five-minute meetings and learn about
things that might be happening in our
company and make decisions quickly
because the decisions I'm making for a
software company in no way are as
important as the decisions that were
made uh in matters of national interest
so uh so I adopted these and we started
a thing at Yaks called Teddy Roosevelt
meetings Teddy Roosevelt meetings are an
hour or two hours people sign up for a
five minute block
I might say travel to a London office
there might be a hundred people in the
London office I would meet with all 100
people in 500 minutes here's how a five
minute meeting Works person comes in
sits down
I'm really careful to not make eye
contact with the person when they're in
the meeting because I found that when
you look down and take notes people tell
you more
so I'm you know taking notes and they
they begin to talk to me about what's
going on
after 10 or 20 meetings you get a really
great sense of what's going on without
doing these big 30 or 60 Minute meetings
and bring a lot of people together and
so five-minute meetings are an
incredibly effective way to uh to really
become effective and get to to calendar
zero it's funny the original inventors
of short meeting times were lawyers
if you've ever looked at your legal bill
you'll note that lawyers bill you in six
minute increments one tenth of an hour
so they are clearly tracking their time
and billing you in these little bits of
you know six minute kind of meeting
times
um so the other thing I've done is
there's it's funny you know each year
when a lot of times when private Equity
buys a company they take out the company
and they try to take out all the costs
and so they have zero based budgeting 3G
capital is famous for doing this and so
they cut out everything each year and
then you have to rebuild your budget
back up from zero they do that for for
money I think people should do that for
their time so constantly I look at my
calendar and I just delete stuff so this
is like doing zero based time budgeting
for your calendar and
one of the very first things to go on my
calendar and I figured this trick out a
long time ago there is a enormous focus
in companies maybe you pop in your
companies do one-on-one sort of weekly
check-ins with your staff like we'll do
half an hour with this person half an
hour with this person once a week and
when you do that
you know and I also like to have a
pretty flat organization so I might have
in my company 15 or 20 direct reports
now if I spend
an hour with every person every week all
of a sudden literally half of your you
know 40 hour traditional working week is
eaten up by these one-on-one meetings
also one-on-one meetings slow people
down so if you and I have a calendar
time on the Block and I need to tell you
something right now I might say you know
I have a meeting with pomp tomorrow I'm
going to wait till tomorrow to give him
this critical piece of information so
not only are you clogging your calendar
up with one-on-one meetings
you're also actually slowing down
information so a different Paradigm and
a better way is to say let's have no
one-on-one meetings with people but
instead let's talk to each other as
necessary so if I need to talk to you
like I'm gonna tell you right I'm gonna
come find you and if you need to talk to
me my door is always open come find me
let's talk ad hoc Jeff Bezos does not do
one-on-one meetings he won't meet with
people he only will meet in small groups
because he knows number two that in
addition to slowing down information
one-on-one meetings that are recurring
tend to become
not work focused and you begin to go
into other places I remember I was given
this advice always have one-on-one
meetings with your direct reports and
I used to be sitting there and after
like the third one they tended to become
kind of therapy sessions and you know
like if you need therapy like I'm not
your guy you know and a lot of times
people walk in and be like how's it
going this isn't a one-on-one meeting
with a team member and so I'm doing
great fine I'm like are you sure and
they're like well I guess I guess now
that you mentioned it I can think of
some things that aren't going great and
there's just no reason to to add that in
to slow people down to do this so I I
clear out all recurring one-on-ones with
people in addition to having five minute
quick meetings I think ad hoc is better
than recurring recurring meetings I
don't know if you saw Shopify
just last week Toby he tweets you know
recurring meetings are a bug and Shopify
literally wiped all of their recurring
meetings off the calendar now think
about I mean how many employees of
Shopify have I'm guessing thousands
thousands ten thousand let's say how
many meeting minutes do you think they
saved from just wiping every single
recurring meeting off the calendar and
it millions and their cost at Shopify is
you know their their primary non-cogs
cost has got to non-server costs has got
to be people so they just increase their
productivity tremendously now some of
that will come back but you know wiping
calendars wiping you know wiping your
calendar clean you'll never get to
calendar zero but I am a huge fan of
trying to get to really really short
crisp meetings you can get done a lot
when you have a little bit of time and
time is the ultimate forcing function as
as death you know looks upon us so
there's two things that Emily come to
mind the first is uh when I started to
say no to meetings
um I thought or maybe it was in
hindsight I realized there's momentum to
it yeah when you start saying yes you
say yes more often when you start saying
no you say no more often and there's
like a momentum to it for sure uh and so
I would say no but and the butt was but
send me an email with exactly what the
uh information is what they ask is or
whatever and I'll quickly get back to
you and what I found was not only did I
save time for me and the other
individual but also I got the
information in a much more digestible
manner because they were forced to write
it down right and so usually what
happens in these like uh kind of one-off
minutes not the recurring one-on-one
meetings but but just somebody say Hey
you know do you have 30 minutes I've
talked about something is it kind of
come in and they would be like well
there's this thing and then this thing
and then oh wait I forgot about this oh
oh wait hold on you don't have this
context and they were like all over the
place
but by having to write it down it was
like very clear like listen you were to
send me this email this is the only
context I have if it's not in here then
I don't have that context and so it made
the uh quality of the decisions that I
would make better as well so it's kind
of a double win and then the second
thing was on the calendar uh at the
start of this year I went through uh and
I did this like huge calendar audit now
there's two types of audits that uh I've
done one is every week
um the executive assistant that I work
with she puts together a report and uh I
got the template from Mateo over at
eight sleep I think he actually stole it
from somewhere else so I don't want to
give him too much credit
um but what we basically do is we go
through and we characterize every single
I'm sorry categorize every single minute
of my week and we know what is for what
business what is what activity all this
stuff at the end of the week I get this
report and it tells me you spent 10
hours doing this you spent 20 hours
doing this and we try to make
adjustments and it's very clear like how
I'm investing my time is a direct
reflection of what is going to have
happen and so if there's a business
that's struggling and I'm only spending
two hours a week on it well we probably
should spend more time on that right and
vice versa so that like we should kill
that business and then spend all of your
time on the one that's doing well yes
and so like look literally we have those
conversations right of like is this not
worth spending any time so that's the
week by week but then at the beginning
of the year I did what I thought of more
as like a macro audit and when I looked
at the macro of what I was doing I was
the structure of my day was off and what
had happened was over time over about a
year I had gotten what I call morning
creep so I know myself in that when I
write when I think when I am most
productive is in the morning and so from
the time I wake up to about 11 or 12
o'clock
I will put myself up against anyone I
could be hyper productive right and I
can think very clearly and that's the
best time I write
but over the last year I started to take
meetings at 11 10 30 10 9 30 9 to the
point where I was taking me is at 8am
and so we basically just went back to
the drawing board and we said okay
basically the zero base time budget
how do I want to spend every hour of the
day and rather than go to calendar zero
we actually did it uh try to get to the
same thing but we did it a different way
we blocked the times so from 8 to 11 no
meetings no calls right and we've done
it in a way where like everyone knows he
is doing X during this block of time
then from 11 to 2 there's a block of
time and then two to four is when I'll
take the meetings for the calls and so
when you you kind of do that what it
also does is it forces everyone in the
organization by damn he's only going to
spend two hours meeting with anyone in
the organization today is it really
worth five minutes 30 minutes of that
two hour block and so what happens is
you're pushing decision making you're
pushing responsibility to everyone else
and from what I've seen so far it makes
the organization operate much more
productively but also it allows for uh
people to gain confidence that like they
can do things without having to come to
you I think that is absolutely true
people end up making more decisions they
get to the point faster and you know the
human brain works on chunking the human
brain works on being able to you know
categorize things and when when they can
categorize things at a higher level
that's the executive function that you
want your team to be doing and making
those decisions
in um good profit by Charles Koch I know
you and I share this love of reading and
for those that don't know uh Howard and
I whenever we're reading a book we like
take a picture and send it to each other
and uh we it's always like a 50 50. I
already read that one or like when you
get done tell me if it's good or not
right
um but in good profit one of the things
that I took away from it is they treat
the employees like entrepreneurs what
that means is that they try to delegate
decision making down the decision making
it can only be high quality if everyone
is aligned on what the vision is right
so this is where we're all going you're
a talented person help us get there and
make the decisions that will do that but
then they also compensate people on a
kind of a commiserate uh um you know
perspective as well and they say look if
you deliver a certain amount of value to
the business you are going to get paid
more than if you deliver less value and
so how do you structure both the X which
you took public and then you've got a
new business room how do you think about
this like uh delegation of decision
making but also then compensating People
based on value they create create right
well there's a lot packed into that
question let me start
just go back 30 seconds and say I was
really glad to hear you talking about
working your day
we just got through the new year and
everyone asked me what are your New
Year's resolutions and frankly I do not
have New Year's resolutions I've not
made New Year's resolutions in a very
long time
I make adjustments constantly and you
know at the end it just so you know sort
of December 31st or January 1st just so
happens to be like a random day uh but
what I do try to focus on instead of
making
annual goals which everyone has annual
goals but you you try to focus on
the daily routine and if you can build a
great daily routine then I believe the
longer term outcomes can happen in a
better way so I'm not a morning person
you're a morning thinker I mean I know
because you're up so early and we're all
getting your emails and stuff early in
the morning uh you know I'm a night
thinker but I try to build my days so
that I do something physical so they do
something intellectually challenging so
I take a mandarin lesson probably three
times a week that kind of thing
um and then you know once I've done
those two things then I feel like I'm
ready to take on anything so I think
instead of for people focusing on their
uh annual goals focusing on their daily
routine is how the stoics would do it
and being able to build that up
um and it's funny also because you you
block off your time
I think the the analogy there going back
to sort of time being money would be
just like that's how you've chosen to
allocate your Investment Portfolio and
you've said okay I'm taking you know
this particular piece of my Investment
Portfolio which is my time and saying
I'm gonna put that in I'm just making
this up and the S P 500 which would be
one part another part would be you know
allocated like this so uh you know smart
people the most successful people I know
think about their time just like you
just said which is we're gonna allocate
it like it was our portfolio
um and we're different asset classes and
you know different parts of the time are
different parts but the the way they
think about it is totally by Morning by
time when they know their most
productive least productive and so all
that kind of stuff now shifting gears to
your next question
about uh Charles Koch and uh you know
his market-based management philosophy I
think is what he called it it was even
he even registered the trademark on it
so I'm nervous that I might get a
lawsuit just by uh uh bringing it up in
this in this conversation we're having
that was a great book I I enjoy reading
about him he really had a lot of
advantages in starting a company
um you know he I I don't remember the
exact story but I think his dad started
the company and then he definitely he
his brother took it you know sort of his
dad started it and then they came in and
they were like hey do you want to grow
it and his dad was like oh we got a good
thing going and his dad passed away and
then him his mother you know took it to
the I think that the second largest
privately held company in the world now
yep what's the largest marsh
Cargill Cargill yeah or at least in the
United States uh cargo I think is larger
um and it's estimated that coke
Industries uh I think the latest number
I saw was 125 billion in annual revenue
yeah you know so we talked about how
they Empower people and how they
compensate people and you know you asked
how we did that at Yaks and how we do
that at Rome I mean the one thing I've
learned being an entrepreneur going from
zero to one and Beyond and now back to
zero to one again is just when you're in
different phases of a company's life
cycle you do different things so when
you're running in a 125 billion dollar
annual company he's operating at such a
high level that he's just trying to you
know focus on culture pretty much and
probably some m a
um but the the fact is that running a
private company which I think is kind of
the point is a lot different than
running a public company I ran a public
company for five and a half years I did
22 earnings calls I did you know dozen
appearances on CNBC and it's a lot
different running a private company uh
where you can take a little bit of a
longer term Focus than you know having
to explain to Jim Cramer why EPS is off
a tenth of a point quarter of a quarter
due to currency fluctuations in Europe
which is definitely not my personal
strong suit
um so
you know when you're running a private
company you're not accountable
for that so the way you compensate your
people
is totally different when you're in a
public particularly in Tech you give out
these rsus which is essentially stock in
the company and we can talk about stock
compensation in a second because I have
I have a whole philosophy on this too
um but the rsus people pretty much treat
them as cash I mean it's just it's a way
for a company to
you know give people an incentive but
the reality is that
um it tends to just be cash now you get
them in the future and invest in the
future so of course everyone wants this
is the stock price to be higher but you
know when you're running a private
company if you get a piece of the profit
or something like that you're you're
absolutely incentivized completely
differently and the company itself is
not run on a quarter by quarter base I'm
sure they look at their quarterly
financials but you are not doing things
that you know you're thinking about this
quarter a lot like and
um you know when you're running a public
company you're definitely thinking about
your sales quarter when you ran the
private company and then took it public
is that the biggest difference that you
saw was like that uh quarterly earnings
report
actually no okay the biggest difference
between running a and again it's we're
talking about the size here so once you
get to I'm just making up a number 100
million of recurring
at that number you're a pretty big
company you can be public or not
the biggest difference in addition to
you know
the pub the quarterly earnings call
is the investor base so when you're
private your investor base is VCS
and entrepreneurs whoever you have in
your cap table
and they share one thing they all want
you to succeed
when you're public
you learn quickly that hedge funds
and even famous investment houses
are not all long only and the thing is
you don't know when you're meetings with
an investor if they're long on you or
they're short on you then it gets even
more complicated they don't disclose
that absolutely not
absolutely not because they're not
allowed to or because that would then
give away what they consider to be a
potential Edge in learning something you
know it's funny the way that the
reporting works I'm pretty sure you can
see if people have shares and if they've
short your shares you can't tell if they
own your shares or they've shorted your
shares so it's an interesting kind of
thing to be sitting there saying are you
know are these people with us are
against us when you're private
everyone's with you and it's either
going to be a big outcome or it's not
and they're all taking that sort of
binary risk when you're public it's
uh you know people might not be with you
and by the way they might be with you
for a minute that's the other thing when
you're private your VCS you know they're
with you for eight years well they you
know kind of have the whole life cycle
with you people could come in for a
minute I had people I'd shareholders
come in they buy the stock they you know
get in the stock and they'd be there for
a quarter I'd meet with them they'd say
this is great then I'd meet with them a
quarter later they say we sold out but
thanks we appreciate you you know making
us eight percent this quarter or
something like that so they're in and
out too and so there's a lot of timing
that you don't really think about when
you're you know a private company with
long-term shareholders there's just
there's not a long-term there are
long-term shareholders and you know who
they are often though those seem
long-term shareholders will own your
stock but then they also do complex
stuff like loan it out to shorts and so
they make money on that too so there's a
whole weird sort of it's very complex
very complex
when you start thinking about overlaying
the productivity hacks of your day to
the organization what are some of the
things that you would do in an
organization outside of just the
structure of meetings that would
increase the productivity of the
organization hey guys I hope that you're
enjoying this interview before we
continue I want to quickly remind you
I'm hosting a conference March 4th at
the Miami Beach Convention Center that's
right it's a big venue for a big event
on March 4th I'm bringing together some
of the absolute fan favorite guests from
the podcast in this show and we're going
to debate ideas the event is called
lyceum Miami the lyceum was the public
gymnasium in Athens Greece that ancient
gymnasium was important because it's a
place where people from all walks of
life came together to have a war of
ideas you were able to not only
participate in the debates but also
people could sit and watch some of the
smartest people in the world talk about
important issues that's what we're going
to be doing on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center if you want to
join us go to lyceummiami.com or click
on the link in the description and I'd
love to see you there okay let's get
back to this conversation well you know
I think that it depends on with your pre
or post product Market fit okay and
pre-product Market fit it's super
important to be very close to your
customers
I want to be talking to my customers all
the time in fact you know my new company
Rome we have this Genius Bar where we
engage with all of our customers all the
time and they can chat with us it's like
a support bar they can come in we offer
them Live support if they're
troubleshooting something will show up
to their room and talk to them about
that so I think pre-product Market fit
the most important thing is to talk to
your customers and by the way the vast
majority of startups are pre-product
Market fit they even if they think that
they have product Market fit when the
founders have used their sort of sales
muscle to close some deals you know from
people they know that's not true product
Market fit product Market fit I think is
best described as when your ability to
keep up with demand is limited and uh
and so most startups are actually not
there so pre-product Market fit you need
to be kind of taking in as much signal
as you can from customers which means
observing talking tweaking things seeing
what happens experimentation
post product Market fit
for most Tech starters I'm talking about
software here it becomes all about go to
market and so that's kind of a whole
different ball game and so okay we have
a product that works now how are we
going to keep up with the demand we're
going to hire a cro and we're going to
hire a salesperson we're going to hire a
Vice President of Sales we're going to
hire sales Engineers we're going to hire
sales enablement people we've got to
train these people we're going to have a
whole operation devoted to how to custom
had a customer success had a customer
support we're going to hire and you know
analysts to be looking at all these
different kinds of things and so then
then the ball game becomes uh much more
about go to market and that's an
entirely different phase of the company
and it's almost like running a military
at that point I mean it's like you have
these PODS of people and you have you
know when your pre-product Market fit
and you have a tight team I'm just
making up a number of 12 people
designers Engineers you're all in there
it's primordial soup you're using your
creativity to come up with
what is the winning formula
that is going to get the most possible
customers to buy you you know use and
love and buy our product once you get
past that then you have to hire in like
the generals and the kernels to kind of
figure out how to put teams sales people
together it looks like the military
because you're dividing up territories
you know who's got this territory who's
got the Southwest territory who's got
Europe who's got Japan you know then you
go once you once you get the us then you
go International so
um so in terms of productivity hacks
you know it's it you really have to just
rely on your people because just hire
great people and then basically get out
of their way it's I mean especially if
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing I mean in my case when it came to
comes to scale and go to market like I
legitimately don't know what I'm doing
there so I wanted to find great people
and I did that with hiring Jim Steele
and Dave raminsky who ran sales at
Salesforce Jim was the president of
Salesforce Dave was right with Jim and
running that and so those guys came over
to yxt and helped us build out a real
sales force real professional sales
force in fact you read Mark benioff's
book behind the cloud there's an article
a whole chapter about Dave and Jim so
you know it's funny though because all
the advice you get as an entrepreneur is
you hire the experts and get out of the
way and I did that with our CFO I hired
Steve Cakebread who was the CFO of
Salesforce and took them public in 2003
and so you know got out of the way but
at the same time you lose control
so you don't know how things work like
it used to you you you you know when you
hire your professional sales force they
get in between you and the customer not
intentionally but that's just what
happens because it's the size and scale
and so how do you manage that like
you're hiring these experts yeah you're
deferring to them but ultimately you're
still responsible if things doesn't go
right or let's say the CFO made a
mistake like people yeah they're like
okay to see if I'm in a statement like
you're the CEO of the business so how do
you kind of give them the space to run
and do what they do best and be an
expert but also kind of have the
controls in place whether it's on the
financial side sales side whatever where
you feel still feel like you you kind of
understand what's happening you know on
on the let's see first off don't hire a
CFO that's going to make a mistake you
don't want your CFO to make a specific
you can have your sales people make a
stick you don't want general counsel or
CFO to make a mistake they they don't
they don't get to make a mistake they
they fortunately have you know a
controller Auditors and then they have
Auditors that are looking at their work
to double check it and then they even
have the Auditors have Auditors that are
auditing the auditor's internal audit
making sure that they also are not
making a mistake you can make mistakes
in sales you can make mistakes in r d
but just don't make a mistake when it
comes to financial reporting and there's
there's all kinds of things to make sure
that that that that is unlikely to
happen but putting that stuff in putting
those controls in slows you down it
changes your business you don't you know
when we started early days yes we used
to do these deal you know you could we
would do all kinds of deals to win
customers and they'd look different
they're you know different payment terms
all different types of structures and
stuff you have to standardize and so
standardizing gives you those controls
but at the same time slows you down
when you start to see
um the meetings and then you start to
see the organization you're hiring the
right people what is the biggest mistake
you ever made in business
mistake I ever made in business was in
20 March of 2020 when I decided and
announced to the company right after the
pandemic that I would not let anybody
off
oh interesting so that was uh like a
pride thing in terms of I don't want to
lay anyone off so like let me say it and
I'll like force it into reality or what
was going through your head but we have
1500 people pandemic hit you have all
these media reports of you know and
again you have to go mentally back to
covid March of 2020. not where we are
today complete uncertainty you know
pictures of people in New York hospital
beds piling up you know Italia you know
Italy everyone's whatever so everyone's
freaking out total uncertainty I
announced the company
we will not Lane your jobs are all safe
we will not let anybody off you will
uh
we're not going anybody erase this year
so everyone's salary is going to stay
flat year over year but in return for
that it seems like the human thing to do
right now is to guarantee you all your
jobs and your health insurance during a
pandemic I'm not going to put anybody on
the street and at the moment I was
lauded you know I was everyone was like
that's a great you know the employee
base thought that was great meanwhile
Airbnb laid off
can you know thousands of people
thousands of people they later that year
had a 100 billion dollar IPO
and
my big mistake was it turned out that in
not laying anybody off and telling
everybody weren't gonna let anybody off
that it was a Performance Management
nightmare because a lot of the good
people that didn't get a raise were like
wait a minute I can go to a different
company and switch jobs and get a raise
so why would I stay here so your loyalty
was not rewarded number one and then
number two a lot of people that
were poor or mediocre performance or
like performers were like I can just
like do nothing and I won't get laid off
and so it gave people an excuse
to do nothing and basically removed the
stair the uh carrot and the stick it's a
bad idea to take the carrot and the
stick away yeah fascinating yeah and so
did you have to go back and correct it
at some point you know you you do you do
correct it and you have to correct it
over time it's not the kind of thing
that you can do quickly I think what
hurt me most was not that the people who
didn't perform well didn't you know kept
not performing well it was the people
that were the the best performers that
did that left that didn't show any
loyalty that hurt me the most now I will
tell you
the best people was more painful than
keeping your worst people like the worst
people are already dragging you down
it's like how much worse could they
almost perform but losing your best
people was a big blow it was the fact
that they showed no loyalty that I
thought that in again not everyone not
all the best people left some of the
best people left and when they would
leave for a higher salary somewhere else
after we as a collective unit said hey
we're going to protect all of our people
here you know we're all in this together
with one team
they were unwilling to share the
sacrifice or burden a little bit by the
way today you know you see Salesforce
line people you see all these layoffs
happening and I just you know
I just
wouldn't have done that again that was
it that was a mistake it was a mistake
because it hurt the best people and it
may have saved some of the worst people
But ultimately it hurt the company too
much yeah and I would undo that if I
could yeah it's fascinating
um when you think about Rome the
business you're building now uh I am
very proud to be an investor
um uh it is I'm going to call it a zoom
killer I don't know if you're gonna call
it that but describe a little bit as to
we moved to this remote work world yeah
Zoom works it's fine I use it every day
yep
why even think about going after an area
that already has such a dominant player
who is being positioned in the media and
elsewhere as the disrupter right so it's
not that uh Zoom is some you know 100
year old incumbent company that no one's
tried to take it off like they kind of
were like the startup that just made it
right and you guys are already coming
after them well let me just take a step
back and tell you about what Rome is so
during March of 2020 when we were
talking about you know who to lay off
and what not to live I one day set up a
zoom and when you run a big company or a
small company you're doing zooms all the
time I put a hundred you know and the
bigger the company the longer and more
boring the zoom tends to be and you're
you know you set up those calendar
invites where you add all the people and
you add their email address in and I was
setting up a zoom calendar invite
and I think it was for 100 people and I
forgot to add someone
and when you forget to add someone to a
zoom in a remote world
that person does not exist it's like
they didn't know the meeting was
supposed to happen like nobody told them
they just they blissfully ignorantly go
about whatever they were doing and like
they missed out in the real world if
there was like a meeting going on with
everyone and like a person walked into
the office and saw the people there'd be
like Oh I'm probably supposed to be in
there so it was at that moment that I
had this flash of insight which was well
what if there was a bird's eye view of
all the meetings going on in the company
at the same time that everyone could see
just like in the real world you walk
into an office I walked into your office
here I see it's a bustling office
there's people talking to all kinds of
people here there's you know I see who's
in who's not in who's talking to who and
I get a sense for what the heck is going
on we lost all that when we went to
slack and zoom you you know and what
Zune did a phenomenal job better than
anybody in the world the zoom was the
first video conferencing technology that
worked and Eric rewrote the video Kodak
he didn't use the existing stuff in web
browsers which didn't really work that
well he rebuilt the whole Kodak from
scratch and you know famously left Cisco
and that whole thing so so they solved
the video conferencing technology
problem but what they completely failed
to solve or didn't attempt to Endeavor
to solve was the workflow and so
what we have today is this amazing
technology but our workflow around it's
totally broken things that used to take
two people you know five minutes in the
office to get done right now hey I
walked pomp can you help me with this
thing we we do it like we're done now is
being scheduled for a zoom call for 60
minutes with nine next week and so the
and then the other thing about this
that's funny is you know when you're
scheduling a zoom call for 60 Minutes
next week you know I put you on I put
you on it and it's like well I should
probably be inclusive I'll just invite
everyone to it and so you end up this is
the calendar recorder we were talking
about before the workflow is backwards
the workflow is broken there's too many
meetings the meetings are too long
things that you know could be done right
now are being scheduled next week so
it's slowing companies down and so we
invented Rome Rome is a cloud
headquarters that's the positioning for
cloudhq it does three things it uh it
makes companies it gets it helps them
reduce the number of meetings they have
the average meeting time in Rome is
eight minutes wow
eight minute meetings not down to six
like lawyers we're gonna we're gonna try
to get down to five all right
um
and I'll talk about more about the
meaning second thing does it makes
companies feel more connected ninety
percent of people that use Rome feel
more connected to their company you know
in a remote company or a hybrid company
or even a distributed company and let me
be clear Rome is not just for
remote or hybrid companies the fact is
any company that gets big enough becomes
distributed the X head office is from
Berlin to Beijing we're all over the
place so we put companies together Under
One Roof anyone from anywhere can see
everyone and see who's meeting with who
and pop around and so this vision is
this bird's eye view of the whole
company everyone on one HQ from anywhere
and then the third thing and we'll talk
about this in a second about SAS and my
views on SAS we have a business model
Innovation we only charge for active
user
so where most SAS companies would say
you signed up 20 people you owe me X
dollars times 20 people per month in
perpetuity you say no yes you signed up
20 people but only 14 of them actually
logged in this month or this week and so
therefore you owe me for 14 not for the
20. you got it and it's paid at the end
of the month as opposed to SAS which
says you have to prepare us you have to
guess how many licenses you're going to
need for this year 50 well you're going
to grow okay 60 you know and there's a
sales person sitting there trying to
upsell you more and more and more 60 70
80 and then okay it's 100 you know bucks
a year per user or whatever you have to
prepay that up front for the year we say
we're gonna do active user pricing it's
an all-in-one bundle so we're going to
include the ability to do chat and video
conferencing all this other stuff but
the time you add up the other apps that
we can get you out of by using Rome
it's 2 000 bucks a year for them it's
120 bucks
per active user only for Rome so uh we
have a business model Innovation here
too and I and I worry by the way a lot
about other SAS companies that have
kind of a lot of unused licenses sitting
around as companies try to get more
efficient they're going to just cut that
stuff out of course yeah if you're not
if you're paying for something and not
using it right now and over the next six
months there's a lot of companies trying
to figure out where those are in the
company I see a lot of the Groupon
breakage Groupon would sell you know 100
Groupons or whatever and then only 30 of
them would be redeemed and that's how
they literally made all that's how the
merchants were Groupon made all their
money they could discount it so much
knowing people would buy it and never
redeem so I worry about that in SAS you
see that in SAS a lot but Rome you know
our our ability to and let's talk about
meeting minutes for a second so I said
the average meeting time in Rome is
eight minutes long and it's because when
you use this and you have to see it
you're in this immersive HQ and it's a
2d HQ you can see who's meeting with who
I see pomp is talking to a designer and
I know oh I'm supposed to talk to those
two people about something I pop in for
two minutes and we have a quick
conversation at serendipitous it's ad
hoc I needed to tell you guys about
something and we may or may not be pre
or post product Market fit but I'm able
to have that conversation with you as I
as I need to have that conversation so
I've got the demo I I uh uh went you
showed it to me and let me do my best
maybe to describe uh from The outsider's
View kind of the the initial experience
was uh you can look and see I'll call it
a floor plan you guys uh probably call
it something else but um on a floor plan
what you can see is everyone has kind of
their own offices and so there's
Howard's office or my office so all the
way down the line uh and then there are
conference rooms on this floor plan
where multiple people can all meet uh
but you could also meet in one person's
office so like I could come to Howard's
office virtually knock on the door you
say yep come in we talk I leave I go
back to my office or we could say hey me
you and five other people let's go to
this conference room and we move over so
literally like you would do in the real
world just now you're doing this virtual
experience and the uh kind of I'll call
it auto magically uh all of the people's
video feeds that are in whatever the
one-on-one meeting or the group meeting
it just works right when you go into the
room bam everyone's connected and like
you can just talk uh kind of in that
serendipitous way but then uh probably a
little bit of Showmanship on your part
uh you were like hey let's go to the
theater and I was like what the hell is
the theater and you basically uh send a
message to your entire team and you're
like hey guys meet me and pomp in the
theater and everyone kind of virtually
moseyed their way over and they end up
in this theater section and literally
you could go on stage and you could hold
a company all hands with everyone in the
entire company and then they also could
react and so while you were talking I
think they were throwing Tomatoes at you
they were doing all kinds of different
things there's a boot icon to kick me
off the stage yes they can push me off
the stage like it's very interactive in
terms of how it would be in the real
world and so what's fascinating about
this is uh your comment that this is not
just remote teams that are doing dealing
with this right when I worked at
Facebook I don't know I think I joined
there was like 3 500 people by the time
I left there's 12 000. yeah well guess
what we would have meetings there was
one meeting that's like now this
Infamous meeting in in the growth world
where uh it was all a bunch of growth
people would come and a bunch of people
from the ads team and this is when
Facebook 2014 like it just exploded and
what we would do is we would have the
people in uh Menlo Park
uh we would have some people dial in
from New York but we also have people in
London so the London team the New York
team and the Menlo Park team were all in
this meeting together and in the Menlo
Park Physical location people were
sitting at the conference room table but
there were so many people in the meeting
that then there was benches around the
uh edges of the room and people filled
those up to the point where the guy who
used to run the meeting his name is Mike
Hudak used to sit on top of a filing
cabinet
and like run the meeting right and
that's how packed was but then we had
all the virtual stuff right and you
could imagine the this is way before
anyone realized like hey you should care
about the people on video but it was
kind of like the meeting was happening
in the room and everyone else was just
like kind of sort of there maybe they
would chime in when needed right it
feels like if we had something like this
that meeting would be very very
different today because you would now
have the people in the room and the
people remotely all interacting in kind
of a much more even playing field you
know there's a lot of there's a lot the
fact is any company that gets successful
gets distributed so you know it's not
about five people remote or 50 people
remote or 500 people any successful
operation requires people all over the
world and that's what allows companies
to go to market in different countries
and different regions and have sales
reps people are weworks people are in uh
you know in the field people are doctors
in offices or retail stores and you know
you want to be able to link everyone in
a company together in one HQ to make
that company to bring that to come you
know to really bring that company
together and help them feel more
connected and be able to reduce meetings
and stuff
um but you know in the old world it used
to be that I would try to schedule a
60-minute meeting with someone and now I
can just go right over see see that
they're available knock on their door
have the conversation with them and and
we're done and um and you know getting
into hybrid for a second there's a lot
of opportunities talk about hybrid I
think the zoom room
concept where there's eight people in a
physical room
and there's a TV with eight people
dialed in like the Brady Bunch on Zoom
is fundamentally broken why because if
we're all in a conference room and the
six of us or eight of us let's say we're
in there and there's eight people dialed
in and they all get ahead on a screen
if I'm talking my head always goes over
to the TV I'm always looking at the TV
even if you're right in front of me and
I'm talking to you because I want to
make sure they can see my face it's it's
an awkward interaction now it
technically again this is an example of
technically works but humanly off you
know it's a it's a inhuman way to to
interact and I think a better approach
just to give you an idea of something
that could feel more natural well
actually let me take a step back that
approach was designed by at T for the
1970s Video Phone the original video
phone for the world fair and it works
really well when both conference
students are exactly equal
um
makes sense yep so there's like six
people around one side six people are on
the other side there's a camera and we
look like you know a circle but as soon
as it becomes multiple people on the
screen with different heads from
different places everything becomes kind
of uneven and so a more natural approach
would be you and I bring our everyone
brings their own device to the meeting
forget the TV turn the TV off you don't
need the TV you're in a conference room
everyone has their laptop or their iPad
and everyone has a camera on their own
face by the way think of the experience
for the people that are dialing in the
old way too like I I can see like one
screen I see all these heads of other
people that are dialed in and then
there's one screen where all the people
are in a semi-circle around and I can't
even see who's talking it's too small
like I can't figure out what's going on
so a more natural approach is bring your
own device to the meeting
and you sit there and like you have a
everyone has a camera on them so right
right off the bat
every single human has a camera and is
even on the screen and then uh and then
when I need to talk like I can kind of
if I'm talking to you Pomp and you're
across from me instead of looking at the
TV to make sure that like the people
over there can see me or whatever so I
can see them I just like look at you and
talk and I can look down and the camera
is still on me I don't have to move my
head at all I just I think the future of
hybrid meetings is going to be people
with their own device as opposed to a
centralized big device where we all kind
of have to look at it yeah how much of
um the like video conferencing stuff is
actually screwing up companies versus
it's helpful like is it a net positive
or net negative well I'll give you an
interesting fact about that which is
that the most popular meeting format by
a factor of three to one in Rome is
audio only with screen shares so it's
not just like oh I could call you sure I
can call you but our offices are Audio
Only so there's an audio only room type
people pop in I might need to chat with
you I don't need to turn the video on or
whatever I can worry about like whatever
I just go hey pump can you help me with
X and you're like yeah the answer is why
or do you think about this and I'm like
well hold on let me show you what I'm
doing pull my screen up you can see my
screen we're just chatting chatting
chatting Audio Only over so Audio Only
formats are 3x more popular than video
on and I think people I think personally
the default should be Audio Only and
video can be there as necessary but it
shouldn't be default video and then you
can default back to audio I am the
reason I asked that is it was like fun
and novel at first like oh video like oh
we're like on the computer whatever now
I oh look at my bunny rabbit ears I can
use the filter yeah I hate the video
because it's like this used to be a
phone call right right and then it
became like a zoom which was default
video right and now I'm trying to as
much as possible Force back going to I
think to the point where I was like
calling in
but then you can't see if they do want
to pull something up yep so uh you
basically you have to get onto the app
or online you know from the computer
um but also then they know that your
videos off because it says your name
rather the number like the whole thing
right well like I said we need to get
back to technology that supports the
workflow not the other way around and
your Tech you know what you were doing
before is like we would talk to each
other and or call you as necessary now
everything is anchored around Zoom
technology which is Inc which is
encumbering our ability to interact with
each other naturally and therefore be
creative
you went to a very uh unique High School
uh Thomas Jefferson tell us about uh
this High School in terms of uh when you
were showing me the demo the first time
you kept introducing me to people on the
team like went to TJ went to TJ went to
TJ right
um what's going on with this High School
well there must be something in the
water uh you know I was really fortunate
to grow up on the wrong side of the
tracks in Virginia and then have an out
in having gone to Thomas Jefferson High
School for science and technology which
is a stem High School uh
by the way I'm super pro stem
and none of the companies I've ever
created whether it was yext or confide
which is a mobile messaging app I made
or Rome or anything else I've ever made
would exist without TJ
and
TJ
was
you got to go back to and again the 80s
here it's like stranger things you're
you know riding your bike around the
neighborhood this is the the era uh was
founded
in the DC area
I think in partnership with corporations
because there was a view of Corporations
and again these are government
contractors take Lockheed Martin with
the view that science technology
engineering and math was the path
forward to make and keep you know
America particularly the military to
have the most Cutting Edge stuff and so
in the DC era you have all these
government contractors selling to the
government the federal government a lot
of them live in Northern Virginia and so
this idea of TJ was was incubated and
formed and it became the top high school
in the nation and the way that and
that's an objective measure but you know
uh the way that you got into TJ was
pretty simple you in eighth grade you
took a test it was a math test and I'm
pretty sure they just literally
didn't look at anything else
there's no you know it wasn't like there
was an English component which was
literally just math literally just you
know problem like math problems and uh
and then they cut they cut off the top
you know four or five percent of people
that took the test and they were they
got the letter and they were admitted
and there was no interview process there
was no it wasn't like if you were good
at sports you got in it wasn't like if
you excelled at the flute that you would
you know be help build this you know
community of Excellence or whatever it
was literally just stem
and the consequence of that pop was
you had this bubble of people that were
not there because they wanted to get
into Harvard
that we're not there because they wanted
to get to the best school and escape and
have a better life and make the most
money and become a McKinsey consultant
or whatever people do but they were
there
because they loved stem
they were there because they literally
things like a supercomputer which was
pretty awesome back in you know 1998
when I went to high school which was in
our
uh in our computer lab things like that
like got people going and they would
just like hang out there all day and so
this Vibe I I imagine it was a little
bit like Stanford
um
you know 20 years ago but it was this
this Vibe of everybody just loving stem
and pure no with with no with no it
wasn't commercially focused at all it
wasn't commercially focusing it wasn't
like a stepping stone to anything else
it was just love of stem whether it was
robotics whether it was computer science
whether it was mathematics
um and so the people there were really
self-selected for that and that alone
and
you know I was fortunate enough to meet
a lot of really really really great
people there uh there's been some
notable alums Vlad tennov uh went to TJ
um he's much younger than me of course
um there's other alums that have gone
through there but I met my co-founders
at yext and at Rome and it confide at TJ
and
um it has continued to serve as a really
tremendous uh recruiting bed for us in
in my career where you know we know if
someone was a CIS admin a TJ which is
like the highest honor like the the
students there like ran the school
networks really it's actually funny I
had a call with the principal a couple
weeks ago and they were like I'm sorry
like we can't use Rome it's not approved
by FCPS you know it's not a technology
that's approved and I was just like
chuckling to myself like all I had to do
was like ask assistant admin like Roma
be through the network in like one
second
um
no I didn't want to put anybody up to
that we just they actually but here's
what I did they said sorry can't use
Rome can we use you know the one
approved technology from the school
board is is zoom can we use that and
I've said I'm sorry Zoom is not approved
technology for us to use it Rome
so what would you do a phone call phone
call yeah
I mean it makes sense though yeah when
you think of a school like that yeah
should we have more of them or is it
important to have like a couple of them
that are you know have like the uh
difficulty to get in and you couldn't
replicate 10 000 across the country well
they're changed they're they're this is
a hot button issue right now and I am
not a northern Virginia school board
political expert but what I will say is
that
it does appear that they've changed the
admissions process to focus Less on stem
pure stem
and more on helping
you know people escape and get into a
great College
and you know the school was not founded
to be a college preparatory Institute
like you want to go to like a good
college or you want to go to Princeton I
don't know go to St Albans I'm just
making this up I don't know but this
this place was like just a place to go
and you know learn about stem and get
into that my view is that
foreign
exceptionalism is fundamentally driven
by STEM and that the reason that we have
the standard of living that we have
today is because of stem the reason we
have
you know companies and all the things we
have this wonderful technology the
incredible meta you know medical
capabilities of course everything can be
improved and get better but what's going
to make it better and what's going to
make our economy better is absolutely
you know leaps in technology right and
um
and making sure that we recognize and
have a system to recognize the people
that can excel in that early on and
putting them together with other people
like them early on is absolutely not
just in the interest of the nation but
the interest of all of civilization yeah
I mean it feels like if we have smart
people who are told that they're smart
and are encouraged to try hard things we
probably will be better off
you were preaching to the choir on that
one it goes back to Coke right like if
you think of uh Charles's
um one of his Fascinations is around
creative destruction this whole idea um
and it's top of mind because I I just
read the book
um but
if we are so big
and so successful we could sit back and
say like we're great we're too big to
fail 125 billion dollars of Revenue like
we're good right but this idea of
creative destruction is they actually
view it as a race
if you're my competitor I want to
destroy my business before you do right
and if I can do that successfully then
that means that I have innovated I've
created a new product a new service a
new type of organization a new whatever
to stay one step ahead of you because if
I don't do it you're going to do it
right and it feels like a school like a
Thomas Jefferson although it's not
explicitly said
implicitly there's this go build things
innovate like you kind of it feels
almost like there's like a soft nudge in
that direction
and then we kind of now see you know 20
years later what the results are it's
like pretty impressive failing is okay
billing is key you know it's funny you
mentioned creative disruption from Coke
another book I read recently was
creative selection I don't know if you
of course you've read creative selection
Ken kosinda you got it the keyboard you
know thank God by the way can you type
how do you can you type in your iPhone
really effectively yes okay okay no I
think my fingers are too fat for it or
something I I still I still struggle
every time I don't do two fingers I just
do one yeah okay right just now my thumb
will probably fall off yeah like this is
actually like a weird question uh I
don't think I've talked about this yet
do your thumbs hurt at all
um they hurt more when I used to use a
Blackberry oh interesting you're too
young for a black no I had the uh my my
first like we had the razors and then uh
the remember the sidekick this like you
yeah you'd slide it and you had the real
keyboard yeah the T Keys uh yeah and um
yeah my thumbs hurt sometimes just from
yeah thanks so much and then the other
thing too is uh if you had to put a
score on the degradation the degradation
of your posture
as I'm sliding down the chair here like
literally literally I want to sit up I
was like doing something yesterday and I
just happened to walk by uh this like
mirror looking thing and I looked and I
was like what the [ __ ] who is that guy
right and I was like and like
immediately you like correct your
posture right but you're like dude come
on like we're little you know monkeys
over the keyboard or whatever
um so I think some of that but Ken uh
his whole story is like fascinating
because he basically was like okay how
do we create a keyboard without the
physical Keys we need to do in this
glass right and the problems he
describes in there are problems that
most people wouldn't really think about
and like the big innovation was not
actually the keyboard layout it was the
whole like auto text
yeah which is fascinating right and you
know I what I took away from that was
less about that specific Innovation but
about the way that Apple used demos to
bring ideas to life in a short concise
way
the demo for Steve was the ultimate sort
of Pinnacle of any Apple inventor
Engineers person uh of their of their
career but also the you know
the the fact that when they were all in
there together greatness happened and it
wasn't yet yes there was the individual
that came up with the Breakthrough but
getting that quick feedback from people
um
other like-minded people that shared the
love of wanting to make something great
was the key to it all happening and at
Jefferson TJ there was that feeling a
bit and so when you're you know 15 and
you experience that you can bring that
forward for the rest of your life
there's a lot of teaching people at
Apple by the way
um and uh in fact the iCloud database at
Apple uses the technology called
Foundation DB
which was which was one of the first
databases to
break the acid test conundrum and uh one
of my high school classmates founded
foundationdb which Apple acquired wow
that's crazy how many people do you
think have built a successful company
that were in your high school class my
high school class
well there are 400 I would say 10.
I would say 10 10 to 10 to 10 yeah 10
out of 400 which is a high ratio two and
a half percent right I have a high yeah
High bar for second math right two and a
half percent right yeah I don't do
public math because you know how that
goes
um uh I've done too much public math
over the years well it's right it's
better to run a private company than a
public company you can make mathematical
mistakes yes true
um what is the best like three or four
books that you've ever read if somebody
wants to get into reading uh you and I
share this love for reading what would
you say some of the top books are well
let's go like one for one don't say a
book I say okay so hey guys I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation as you
probably realize we don't run any ads on
this show that's right all the other
podcasts all the other YouTube shows
that you watch they have advertisers we
don't have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pomp
letter it's it's a daily letter that I
write to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis all right let's get back
into this conversation
I
you asked if someone wants to get into
reading I wouldn't recommend this one
for one for anybody who wants to get
into reading but it is my all-time
favorite book and I don't know if you've
read it
it's called Google Escher Bach used by
Dr David hofstetter he you might want to
warm up to him a little bit before
jumping into it because he can be quite
tedious uh but goodle Escher Bach is
this just insane book about how your
mind works and he you know Escher was
the artist that makes all these
paradoxical images like the hands kind
of drawing each other or like the
impossible buildings where you walk up
staircases that couldn't possibly exist
and a better book by hofstetter that you
might start with is called I'm a strange
Loop okay um that one you'd see in
airports and stuff and it really gets
into cognition
he also wrote a third one and I guess
I'm really going deep on offsetter here
called patterns and Essences and that
one gets into how your mind works and
how the human brain uh uses
categorization it's specifically to
chunk things together and reference each
other
um and so if you have interest in how
your mind works not at like a you know
not like a biological level but like you
know trying to understand the brain is
is uh the study of his career and he he
approaches it from a from a in a a a
perspective that we can like kind of
relate to so I love hofstitter Google
Usher Bach is this like Masterpiece
um I might not start with that one but
it probably is my favorite book of all
time wow g-e-b it's known as there's
like a cult kind of following around it
too among some nerdy people so you would
definitely like it uh I don't know now
I'm nervous
um so I'm gonna say two one that I know
you've read actually talked about it and
then one that most people uh won't have
read uh the rise of American growth uh
is to me it's super dense charts numbers
and all this stuff but it really
highlights from what 1870s to like 1940s
give or take uh literally the rise of
American growth and how so much
Innovation happened there and one of my
favorite data points is like uh
airplanes go just as fast today as they
did in like the 1940s and 50s
there's been no real innovation in speed
right the worst is actually we had the
Concorde right that was faster yes and
we don't have it anymore it makes me so
sad yeah it's crazy so there's that
one's fantastic very dense really
difficult for some people to get through
but if you enjoy that stuff uh and then
the other one is uh the book we were
talking about before I was showing you
in the office it is uh laid out like the
Bible so
uh just take out the Green Salt but uh
50 Cent yes the rapper and Robert Greene
the author wrote a book together called
the 50th law a play on Robert Greene's
48 uh Powers
um or 48 Laws uh of power and in the
book they basically Robert Green goes
through all these different uh things
and it's really about overcoming fear
like that's the the general premise of
the book uh but he overlays 50 cents
life events on top of his writing and so
he talks about all these different uh
details
um and I've given the book now to a
couple different people and like they're
from very different walks of life and
they all come back to me and they're
like yo Loki when you gave me that book
I thought I was stupid but like that was
actually a fantastic book so I'm just
gonna keep beating the drum and uh maybe
Robert Green will give me like a
percentage of uh of sales on that one
right what other ones all right um so I
I like to try to try to study people so
Doris Kearns good one is I think maybe
the best presidential historian I'm sure
you've read all her stuff I mentioned
Billy Pulpit which about TR is the best
she also uh had a couple of others but
she wrote one on leadership that tied
together uh TR and FDR and uh Lyndon
Johnson and I didn't understand I knew
obviously the relationship between the
cousins but I hadn't understood that
FDR really helped Lyndon Johnson when he
was a
I guess congressman from Texas and kind
of identified him this was like in the
the early you know early 40s before FDR
died
that
in late 30s as like a potential person
that could be the you know a president
United States and so that that
connection was not known to me
um and so that was fascinating for me to
to for me to read that and it was
interesting by the way she's got Lincoln
in there too so you know she's she's
well covered yeah um but you know it was
it was fascinating for me to learn about
that link which was one that I had not
understood before
a curious Mind Brian Grazer of course uh
which is a uh is a great one uh all
about curiosity and and how important it
is I like to think that uh I um better
or worse and be able to have the
Curiosity conversations just publish
them well he has them in private
um but another book that uh and he's the
guy that would reach out to people just
sort of hey I have nothing that I want
from you except 30 minutes of your time
yeah and I'd love to just talk talk
right and he did it with
um I think former presidents he actually
uh although it wasn't under the pretense
of a curiosity conversation he had with
Fidel Castro with a bunch of like other
movie producer people and uh he tells
that story
um maybe he's using it as an excuse
and he met with uh you know obviously
movie stars and all that type of stuff
but it was really trying to get and meet
with people that are outside of
um uh his world and one of them I think
if I remember correctly in the what
1980s the riots in La uh happened right
and
um he met with the police chief like the
day the riots kicked off
he just had it on the meeting he thought
for sure it's gonna get canceled or
whatever he shows up and like the way he
describes it is like there's a lot of
police at the police station that day
right and he still sits and he meets
with the uh with the police chief and
he's like it was fascinating because I
saw what was going on out in the streets
I saw the news and then like I just you
know by the luck of the draw I was able
to meet with a guy uh who was like the
responder wow right and like see how he
was interacting internally uh on the
same time so that one's always a good
one what else uh you know my favorite
Business book and again it's going to be
cliches definitely zero to one I think
Peter Thiel just absolutely nailed every
possible Concept in there I even kind of
have some passages in my head you know
my favorite line in the entire book is
if you want to build a big business
don't build an undifferentiated
commodity business and when I just I I
it's like I think pulled out like in
like a you know a special special freeze
and
that that whole kind of idea where
you know there's pretty much two two
kinds of businesses those that are
Commodities and those that are
monopolies
it's true yeah it's better to be dealing
with Anti-Trust people than to you know
be just chopping your prices over time
um and that that particular book I just
I think absolutely you know encompasses
so so much and again we're all we're
talking about non-fiction here here
predominantly
um do you read a lot of fiction not
really you I don't think I've read a
fiction book this is gonna sound
horrible in like a decade so I read
um the foundation
series which is uh a Sci-Fi series
because I saw Paul Graham tweet about it
and I was like okay was it good yeah but
I mean I didn't
I feel like I could get most fiction
from watching Star Trek
like this is I'm gonna get absolutely
blasted for saying this
never watched Star Trek never watched
Star Wars uh I don't really read fiction
like any kind of stuff I would say that
did you read The Fountainhead
uh yes but like in college years and
years ago
um I think the last fiction book
that I read that I can remember like
immediately is
um
uh damn what are the three books so when
you join Facebook uh Sam lesson I don't
know if you noticed yeah uh Jessica yeah
he he puts the information
um yeah and so he was at Facebook and he
put together or at least had a hand in
selecting the three books that product
managers would get right and one of them
was Snow Crash okay like you know pretty
telling pretty pretty forward-looking um
there's two others I forget what they
were but snow crash was probably the
last like fiction book that I remember
uh reading and
um
it was like fascinating like you joined
this place and and it's supposed to be
you know this amazing company that's
growing really fast like all these
things and like the handy fiction books
yeah and like it just like kind of spoke
volumes I think I think the one fiction
book that I loved is uh Ready Player one
yeah I watched the movie I didn't read
the book oh the movie was awful really
Oh I thought it was I mean you might
have liked it but I mean if I read the
book I would have thought the movie was
right the other the other way that
you're gonna start to read fiction again
you're gonna discover the the greatest
author of
I think last century was real dull who
rolled doll you know James and the Giant
Peach all the kids oh yeah yeah like
Charlie the problem is you know when
you're when your kids get old enough you
read this to them and you realize when
you get through the final book you do
the whole series Matilda roll doll you
do James and the Giant Peach Charlie and
chalk Factory Charlie and the Great
Glass Elevator and then you're done
and there's nothing else nearly as good
until you get to Harry Potter yeah and
then you know that's its own thing but
at that age
The Genius of the writing and the
storytelling but I did worry a lot about
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory I'm
sure you're familiar with the story
right so you've seen that movie Charlie
goes he wins the golden ticket he ends
up being sort of the chosen one and
Willy Wonka gives him the Chocolate
Chocolate Factory and I thought to
myself like Charlie's main problem
is that
Willie gives him this Chocolate Factory
he is worth nothing and he's come and
comes upon this Chocolate Factory that's
worth you know billions of dollars
Charlie can't pay the tax bill on that
it's kind of like in Home Alone what was
uh what was the dad's uh you know
profession how do you have that mansion
and how did he pay first class for all
those people to go to you know Europe
makes you wonder it's big questions just
a little bit I also uh was in New York
recently and I went to uh the Titanic
exhibit which you can take a guess there
was two people who went me in Plano I'll
let you decide who uh whose idea it was
um but I enjoy going to that type of
stuff just because you learned right and
uh and so we go it was actually like
very well done right um they kind of
have uh all these different stops and
and they have a bunch of uh things you
know original uh pieces of the Titanic
and pictures of people and like all the
stuff but of course when you get to the
end uh every single couple has to have
the debate like if Jack got on the on
the door like you know would he still be
alive right didn't it didn't the
director recently answer that and say
there was only room for one person well
I mean I I hear what he's saying but
I've seen the door before and you know
two humans could get through your door
you know and then you get into the
weight debate you know bad debate of
course
um
I have two questions for you and then
I'll let you go one when you read a book
what is your process do you read Kindle
physical book audio book do you
highlight do you note take what do you
do when you read books always buy the
physical book and I tend to buy more
than I get to there's what's the
Japanese phrase I forget the Japanese
phrase that means there's far greater
knowledge than you could possibly have
and so that's why we all when we look at
and gaze upon a library it looks
beautiful to us because you see so much
more than you could ever possibly hope
to know and that in a way is comforting
so
I have a bunch of books that I don't
read is what I'm trying to say from
Amazon and
I try to order them you know when I see
somebody like you tweet about like I
bought Paul Graham we mentioned him
before he tweeted about this
book called life in an English
Countryside and it's just like a you
know it's it's a his it's a historical
book probably written in the 60s but
it's about the Medieval Times in London
and how about you know how the meals
were served and I have this thing and
it's kind of sitting on my desk like and
I'm thumbed through it like I'm not
gonna read it but I still bought it so I
have I I keep a constant flow coming
that is more than I could possibly keep
up with and I feel guilty when I don't
read one but that's good see I don't
feel guilty I I do the exact same thing
if I hear a book or somebody I respect
or or you think fondly of and they say
something about a book I buy it
immediately right and uh I have come to
the conclusion that I don't spend any
money on anything like I literally have
a couple T-shirts a couple pair of pants
like I just it isn't interesting to me
and uh I don't feel like
um oh wait sir I don't feel economic
guilt it's not like oh I waste the money
well but here's the thing is I have said
to myself the one thing that I will
always spend whatever amount of money
that I want to right I don't care about
dinners and this and that and also books
I will always buy books and so like you
know I I've bought a lot of books on
months and some books I don't buy a lot
and I have two piles
one pile is I want to read the full book
the other pile is what I think of as the
Sprints so it's like a marathon and
Sprints the marathons I'm gonna read the
whole thing the Sprints I will say to
myself I'm going to read 10 pages of
that book today right and it may take me
six months to finish the book or to
finish enough of the book where I get
the point right but I'm reading it in 10
page increments where it's almost like a
break from the actual book that I'm
reading so that I can get a little bit
of it but like it's either too dense or
it's not something I'm like super
interested in or whatever so kind of
like the medieval meal book would be
perfect skip ahead do you ever skip
ahead
no because if it's not good
I almost get to the point where I'm like
if it's not gonna stop right like I'm
not married to the idea of I have to
finish books and some books like you
kind of read and you're like I don't
know maybe 100 pages in 150 Pages you're
like I get it yeah right right other
books you're like man I wish they had
you know gone 500 more pages right and
so uh I try to find the ones where I
wish there was more than the ones I'm
like okay like I'm done but once I feel
like I got it I just drop it I think
this year I saw a Lex Friedman tweet
that he had like 28 fiction books he was
gonna read like 1980 you know 1984 Brave
New World Brothers cameras over like I
did that like 10 years ago and I read
pretty much all those so that sort of
encompassed my my sort of fiction for a
long time and I did them all they were
all pretty good except the Russian ones
were just so tedious my God I could
literally get through brother brothers
cameras over men yeah see like that
stuff's just not like super interesting
maybe maybe I'm making a mistake right
but like I just haven't oh I'm
anti-recommending it to you right okay
all right definitely do not read it it
was just a long tedious story with no
point yeah now of course you know I
mentioned that on Twitter and was
scolded for misinterpreting all of the
you know brilliant literature and I'm
sure I'm sure there are many people who
deeply loved it and respected it and I
am simply not an Aficionado enough to
have appreciated it but I just did not
like it at all do you think that there's
some people who uh are like predisposed
to fiction versus non-fiction or is it
like something happens in your life
because I I let's actually go let's
actually chunk this up to back to
hofstetter I bet the human brain
is receptive to stories and if you look
at stories they're the best way to pass
information along that's why even across
you know cultures in different places
end up telling similar stories and you
know you have these motifs in your brain
um
a great book that I loved was Carl
Jung's autobiography I don't know if
you've read that that was spectacular
and you know he would get into the
symbolism and get into this idea that we
have sort of every human brain has
figures so whether or not certain brains
are more disposed to that I think all
human brains are disposed to certain
religious almost figures that appear in
stories whether it's in Aboriginal
tribes you know around the world or
Native Americans or English or Indian
like you see the same characters kind of
appearing for societies that never talk
to each other so that means I think we
are all predisposed to to stories and
characters and these motifs that
the best politicians figure out how to
tap into that and use those characters
and narratives and stories to so the
absolutely is there something innate in
our brain that that is receptive to
stories no question yeah
I just am not
super drawn to the fiction I love but
like here's the thing what's crazy is
the biographies and autobiographies I
absolutely love those are stories of
course right but but it's like True
Stories versus like the the fiction
stories and then you know my uh maybe
guilty pleasure is uh on YouTube you
tell me first what you watched on
YouTube and then I'll tell you what I
watch well just like you don't read any
fiction
I don't watch much YouTube except you of
course okay but you don't watch like uh
any YouTube no documentaries no anything
really oh wow so I am like obsessive
about uh documentaries some of them are
like actual you and I would think of as
documentaries some of them I've
mentioned uh before that this guy uh
Phineas is the name of the YouTube
channel sounds like a separate piece
I I don't want to waste uh the next uh
week of your life but he does these like
20 30 minute uh documentaries on great
investors so he's got Peter Lynch and
Warren Buffett and Warren Buffs the
reason when he did
um and they're just like very well done
because it's like obvious that this is
somebody who's learning how to do
storytelling right but and he's not like
some big production company right so so
it's uh uh pretty interesting
um and then I watch a lot of interviews
so I've got a I don't know maybe 20. can
I ask you who do you think the best
interviewer is
I don't I I don't think that there's a
best interviewer because I think what
happens can I ask you a different
question then okay what's this what is
the secret to being a great interviewer
listen
just listen
right the reason why I say I don't think
there's a best interviewer is because I
actually think people
um
they have good days and bad days and
they go through these like Cycles I see
it even with myself but
um there's episodes that I'll watch with
somebody and I'm like
goat right like like that was amazing
they got everything out of that guest
right and then there's ones that you
watch with the same exact interviewer
and you're like almost like a slow car
crash and
my conclusion on
why that happens is because you can't
evaluate just one side of the
conversation
a conversation is give and take there's
two participants and just like there's
no good company culture or bad company
culture it's all about fit right where
you could take one employee and put them
in a company culture and another one
hates it one loves it it's all about
like the match right same thing in an
interview called Pareto optimization
and so when you think about uh that is a
dynamic right now it's not about who is
the best interviewer it's actually about
who are the best combinations the best
people and so Paul and John yeah if you
pull out like um one of my favorite CNBC
clips of all time is uh when Carl icon
and Bill Ackman jump on live and they're
yelling and screaming at each other
it's like that's like electric you know
entertaining Television right what is
that equivalent when it comes to
interviews
um and uh I asked actually recently I
said you know what's the best like
podcast episode of all time and
um I think the person I agreed with in
all the comments was uh Andrew huberman
said hands down not even close Jocko
interviewed uh this guy Johnny Kim have
you ever heard of Johnny so Johnny Kim
uh I'm definitely gonna screw this up
but he was a Navy Seal in Fallujah he
was part of Jocko's team I believe he
then went on to become an astronaut and
then went to I think it was Harvard
Medical School and became an MD
[Laughter]
crazy right
literally as a kid I forget all the
details but like there was a like a
broken home situation and if I I don't
want to misspeak but I think what
happened was uh at one point like the
police like
I think it was his dad in the attic and
there was like gunshots like it was like
like a super screwed up childhood and he
went on to like all these
accomplishments and you listen to things
like four and a half five hours or
whatever
and you're just like that is an
extraordinary individual right and him
and Jocko Jocko is not only a good
interviewer but also there's like a
level of trust they're on the same team
like the ability to talk about certain
things the shared experiences all the
stuff you listen to and you're like man
this is one of the best conversations
ever documented right you know it's
funny you mentioned CNBC I once had to
interview Mark Hamill I know you don't
watch Star Wars but it's famous okay so
you know I'm sitting there we have a
conference I'm like well how the hell
you know what do I possibly ask Mark
Hamill who by the way he's an easy
interviewer and I'm the easy interviewee
and I'm not I have no idea what to ask
this guy so I asked Carl Quintanilla
from CNBC I said Carl you know what in
your opinion is the best way to
interview somebody and what is the key
to being able to do a good interview he
said
you ask them about a moment
ask them about a the instant where they
felt something or they learned something
because when you get to that moment
that's how people get in to their own
head and open up so I've always used
that when I and again I'm not an inter
person who interviews people but I use
that you know what tell me about the
moment when X when you realize something
and that really gets people going so
Carl told me that different Carl
different CNBC cross yeah but that's a
great uh tidbit well it's all about
moments right one you know the moments
it's five minute meetings for Teddy it's
eight minute meetings for Rome it's six
minute meetings for lawyer and it's the
Magic Moment from Carl Cantona I'm gonna
mispronounce his name but do you know
who uh narwhal is I do not know Narwhal
[Laughter]
I'm about to open up a whole world
so he is uh a guy who let me paint a
picture of him
um you ever like uh see like people
pretending when they go to the golf
course and they have like uh maybe they
have like a striped pants on they've got
like a really weird like 1970s almost
like a wallpaper style like a golf shirt
and they've got like a uh one of the
little hats on right and it's like it's
a look right
that's what he wears okay like day to
day
but he interviews the world's top
hip-hop artist
and he is lights out as an interviewer
because it's not the questions that he
asked it's the work he does before the
interviews
so he's and he's been doing this for
like years and years and years right and
he will literally
in the middle of the interview he will
ask questions of the guest right
and they'll be like dude how do you know
that
who told you like not like oh you went
on Google and spent like five actually
you find something personal that really
gets them going like I told my best
friend a secret in 12th grade
and nobody knows that that person's my
best friend and you just repeated to me
word for word what the what the secret
was right how do you know how do you
know that and they'll like stop the
interviewing like how like what the [ __ ]
right
um the other thing he does is he gives
them gifts to start the interview
sometimes and they're things that like
you know uh I think he had like Chance
the Rapper maybe or something he like
gave him like a a vinyl record but the
vinyl record was of a previous artist
that no one really knew chance was a
huge fan of when he was a kid and it
came from the exact Record Shop that uh
chance used to go to as a kid wow and so
you're just like dude like that is
that's an incredible amount of work
right
and then it's like when I bring Chris
Harris to a dinner with you and he's
like you know I roomed with your brother
in college yeah yeah
which is like
the world's small right but also but by
the way if your name is nardwhal like
you're gonna be famous
yeah and he also he's just like quirky
yeah so it's like you you almost set
someone up to not expect a lot and then
you have this like hard-hitting not like
gotcha type journalism but more so just
like I did the work right and I think
people respect the [ __ ] out of somebody
who does the work right and so uh it's
people like that right I'm always on the
look so actually if you are watching
this right now or listening and you know
of somebody who does stuff like that
like just tweet at me leave in the
comments whatever I'll find it
um but those are the people who like
fascinate me right because they're able
to get information out of people
um that just like shows who they are as
humans right well and that's what Oprah
does right she gets people to really
open up that's the idea but it's like
it's on television yeah do they really
open up will they really tell you the
truth as Prince Harry did well in the
book I don't know I'm not gonna read
that did you see the uh uh the
controversies
I've read about the controversies like
the two that
I I don't know they weren't surprising
or were surprising uh it actually
weren't was like he's like yeah me and
my brother like fight yeah wait you
fought with your brother and he and he
like pushed you over wait how many
brothers do you have yeah I have four
brothers trust me that happens like that
that still happens right right right I'm
sorry to hear that yeah but I was kind
of like okay yeah um and and uh then the
second one was uh he claims that he
killed 25 people at War as an Apache
helicopter pilot
be wrong you killed people it's like
he's a combat helicopter pilot right who
was awarded things for seeing combat
right like yeah probably right and uh I
think that people when they saw like the
headlines they thought that he like
walked up to someone like pointed a gun
and like you know shot him right right
and he's like no no like I was like in a
helicopter like yes we still see people
running in like all stuff but like it is
a little bit different than you know
he's a Navy SEAL and he's like whites of
the eyes in the middle of the night type
stuff
um so I don't know it was just like why
do people care right like let the guy
live his life let the guy live his life
but before they care because he's making
a big deal of it yeah if you write the
book I guess he's trying to make money
yeah well does he have to make money yes
right he got cut off right uh one of my
favorite stats from last year is I did
not know that the Queen of England or
the now the king gets paid a dollar per
head of every Australian citizen every
year that seems about worth it
if you think I I looked at it before but
they've got you know a couple million
people and so like just that alone like
they're getting a one dollar tax per
person in Australia well you know if you
tax people without representation as
they may have learned in the past bad
things can happen it's just a lot harder
when you're all the way in the middle of
the ocean in Australia and they live
very far away that's true they can't
send people to Yorktown yeah but like
vice versa can they send people to
Australia you know I don't think that
those two countries are going to end up
at War yeah but just like what if
Australians just like we're not paying
anymore wait who pays who for this
Australians come out of their wages like
a federal tax like it's like a line item
or is it just like I'm not I just know
that somehow uh the king or queen gets a
dollar per head but Australian dollar or
British pound I guess good question too
yeah but like when you start to think
about it it's like what if they all
shines you're just like no we're not
paying it we're not paying anymore I
think with the UK really like kick them
out show up no would they just like show
up and they give us the money you know
I'm not really sure how their whole
system of government works but does the
Queen have to sign off on their prime
minister in some way
so this is fascinating too because uh
who is it Ryan holiday uh in his latest
book
um he talks about how the queen is
actually has no power
like the queen does not actually make
decisions the queen does not you know
whatever and I guess not the king
um so there's like a separate and
distinct government function
but like no one wants to piss off the
king or queen right and so you almost
have to like rule by influence rather
than rule by Authority a very
interesting uh Dynamic it's kind of like
running a sales force
I think a lot about military is very
authoritative leadership like yeah you
have a rank on your chest yeah like
mine's higher than yours like do what I
say right
um
there's authoritative leadership for
sure in uh corporations but um it's a
lot of influential leadership as well
right that uh people kind of forget
about yep well it's funny because
Technology's like slack have shifted the
balance from and frankly any technology
that helps people communicate faster and
better
I don't want to say undermines but
reduces the needs for authoritative
hierarchies
because if you think about something
like channels like slack channels like
you know anybody that wants you can make
up their own channel and call it
whatever they want and add whatever
topic they want to it and therefore
start a movement
so you know it used to be that all
Communications from a company were
top down there's a hierarchy there's a
president and a vice president in a you
know area vice president and you know in
a sales force you have these layers
um and you know you'd relay the message
down and no longer is that necessary to
do so
um
yeah it's been it's been interesting I
think in a military
you you obviously still need that in a
tech company it's interesting how few
people you may need to run a big tech
service
it's a different world
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about Rome
you can always find me on Twitter at
Howard
I'm OG so at Howard and we asked we also
got at room on Twitter but on our site
it's ro.am r o dot am is the website and
then Twitter we're at Rome and then you
can find me at Howard
I always enjoyed talking to you I expect
more book recommendations in 2023 I will
send mine as well and I'll do this again
in the future love seeing you pop